(upbeat music)
If you have a not-so-green thumb like me,
you'll love this tip from a plant expert.
Here's plant stylist, my favorite, Hilton Carter.
You gotta take a look.
When you decide to water your plant, just like others,
you're gonna do it nice and easy,
slow and steady around the entire pot,
making sure that every single root
in there has a moment to pull in moisture.
That is important.
And because you haven't watered this desert plant in weeks,
it's going to need to be watered completely through,
all the way through all the roots,
and all the way down into your base tray.
Now we're talking about water.
Water for the snake plant is one
of the reasons people kill it.
Overwatering.
So you wanna be aware of that.
Signs of an overwatered snake plant
is soft, yellowing tissue.
As you can see,
all of the tissue is turning very yellow and very mushy.
And then when it leans like that,
that is a clear sign that it has been overwatered,
and now it is dying.
But an underwatered snake plant leaf
will show signs of just, let's say browning,
dry browning on the edge of the foliage.
But if that happens,
what you can do here is you can kind of trim that off.
You can use your nail, maybe.
Trim that off, and there it is.
It's gone, and now you still have the rest
of your leaf looking great.
But if you overwater,
there's nothing really you can do here.
So once you see dying foliage happen like this,
this is probably a good time to start pruning
that plant back to at least give all of the foliage
that still has good life in it the time,
the moment to really grow, to really thrive.
I need more Hilton Carter in my life.
Chip and Joanna, where can I find him?
Well, he hosts the Guide to Houseplants
and Caring for Common Houseplants workshops
on the Magnolia app,
where you can grow your houseplant skills.
Well, thumbs up for green thumbs.
(upbeat music)